ja putin will sich die besetzten Teile
der Ukraine unter den Nagel reißen das
haben wir heute morgen von ihm gehört es
soll sogenannte Referenten geben also
Abstimmungen im besetzen bieten und wir
wollen uns das mal auf der Karte ganz
genau ansehen was planen Putin dort also
ganz genau laut Moskau und das ist
natürlich in Moskau geplant auch wenn es
von den jeweiligen Marionetten
angekündigt wurde soll es drei
Referenten geben ein hier unten im
Bereich herson in der Region und wir
sehen hier auch das Teile von Nicola
live besetzt sind da wird morgen gerade
gehört auch nicolajev die Ukraine etwa
10.000 dort unter unsicher Kontrolle
stehen sollen hier mit abstimmen hier
haben wir im Regionen in der Region
Donetsk ein weiteres Referendum und ein
drittes Referendum in der Region luhansk
wie diese Referenten ausgeben ist völlig
klar dass das russische Staatsfernsehen
heute morgen schon gesagt alle drei
Regionen werden sich Russland
anschließend werden also für Russland
stimmen das also eigentlich ja eine eine
rein technische Frage das noch mal
durchzuführen die Propaganda hat längst
entschieden um Moskau längst entschieden
wir das ausgeht fraglich ist noch was
mit SAP Berisha wird das ist dann uns
ziemlich große Region hier und auch die
letzten Teile in die unterrussischer
Kontrolle stehen dort soll es die
erstmal keine Referenten geben sondern
man sagt zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
vielleicht aber diese drei Regionen
sollen darüber abstimmen dass die
Russland angehören und wir haben schon
gehört natürlich von den Russen sie
werden auch dafür abstimmen dieses
Ergebnis ist gar nicht fraglich wenn man
es eh schon sozusagen beschrieben hat im
Moskau und dann eben Teil Russlands
werden auch direkt danach wir haben das
von der Krim von 2015 noch in Erinnerung
das hat also keine 48 Stunden gedauert
zwischen diesem Fake Referendum was
damals hier abgehalten wurde und eben
der Doomer die dann in einer Diktatur
ganz normal innerhalb von Stunden
abgestimmt hat darüber dass das auch zum
Teil von Russland jetzt wird warum
funktioniert das alles überhaupt nicht
ja wir gucken uns das ganze mal an hier
neue Aufnahmen aus dem Osten des Landes
das sieht erstmal gar nicht spektakulär
aus ukrainische Soldaten die hier
durchgehen darüber steht Billa gorov
ganacha also Bela gorowska gehört uns
aber das Besondere ist dass Mela
gorowska oder Mila hurivka auf
Ukrainisch die erste Stadt ist in der
Region luhansk die seit 3 Juli wieder
unter ukrainischer Kontrolle ist das
heißt während putinat erzählt dass hier
alles bald russisch sein wird dringt die
Ukraine genau in diese Gegenden vor die
er eben als russisch oder als
Volksrepubliken bislang charakterisiert
hat und das ist eben ganz spannend wir
schauen uns das ganze auch mal kurz auf
der Karte an im Osten des Landes und
sehen dass jetzt hier in der Region
luansk das hier und du Hans eine sehr
große Region ganz im Osten des Landes
hier haben wir den ersten kleinen
Schnipsel der wieder seit dem dritten
juli stand alles unter russischer
Kontrolle der jetzt seit drei Tagen
wieder unter ukrainischer Kontrolle
steht das also der erste forsch ist der
Ukrainer dahin das heißt Putin kann in
keiner einzigen Region auch nur sagen ja
die die ist ja komplett unter unserer
Kontrolle deshalb stimmen wir da auch
komplett ab sondern sämtliche Regionen
werden umkämpft und sämtliche Regionen
in sämtliche Regionen dringt die
ukrainische Armee aktuell weiter vor was
auch von Putin heute gehört haben ist
diese teilmobilisierung 300.000 Mann
sondern mobilisiert werden die Frage ist
mit was und wir schauen uns mal die
Bilder aus easium an
russland hat allein beim Abzug aus isum
aus der Region tragiv und Isis um 300
Militärfahrzeuge und einfach
zurückgelassen und verloren das heißt es
ist völlig fraglich womit denn diese
neuen mobilisierten Leute kämpfen sollen
russland hat nichts mehr russland hat
keine Panzer mehr russland hat keine
Fahrzeuge mehr wir sehen in den letzten
Wochen haben es immer wieder
thematisiert das mittlerweile aus den
50ern aus den 50ern gebaute Panzer t-62
zum Beispiel in die Ukraine gebracht
werden
und wir wissen auch dass Russland seine
Exporte von Panzern Richtung Algerien
und Indien zum Beispiel eingestellt hat
um eben diese exportpanzer die
eigentlich für ganz woanders gedacht
waren eben doch in der Ukraine
einzusetzen mit anderen Worten die
Panzer wenn immer älter und immer
notfallmäßiger beschafft was weil
Russland eben so viel verliert in der
Ukraine und die große Frage ist wirklich
was will man denn hier machen wie will
man denn die Leute darin hinschicken
einfach nur mit dem Gewehr in der Hand
so sieht's fast aus der neue gepanzerte
Verbände hat Russland nicht mehr im
Einsatz und kann sie nicht mehr dazu
packen jetzt haben jetzt gesagt wie
nach Russland ist trotzdem müssen wir
nur sagen dass das Land weiterhin eine
massive Militär macht in der Ukraine hat
und das sind Bilder einer russischen
Drohne aus brav Düne auch in der Region
und wir sehen hier ein ukrainischen
Gegenangriff am 16 und 17 wir sehen hier
die ganzen gepanzerten Fahrzeuge ein
zwei drei vier fünf die sich hier lang
entwickeln und das war einer der
Angriffe wo die Ukraine auch versucht
hat hier ein Dorf zurück zu erobern dass
er ein weiteres in Carson und wurde
dabei aber schrecklich von der
russischen Artillerie aufgehalten und es
sind auch viele Fahrzeuge dabei
vorangegangen das heißt Putin ja er tut
so als hätte er hier die Macht und
vieles davon ist Schein weil wir haben
es gesagt es ihr kommt kaum noch weiter
während wir hier die zerstörten
vulkanischen Fahrzeuge sehen dennoch
bleibt Russland eine massive Bedrohung
auch in der Ukraine und sorgte hier
weiterhin jeden Tag für Tod und
Verderben und der ukrainischen
Zivilisten und auch Soldaten
[Musik]